how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have some pretty big spider-man
leaks and they're different than we've
really had before
in the fact that they actually describe
why some things that are going to happen
in spider-man no way home
are actually happening specifically in
regards to
not just the main villain but the other
villains as well because as
most everybody knows there have been a
lot of villains reported and rumored to
be in this movie it's almost going to be
an
unofficial sinister six or an official
sinister six if they decide to
call them that and as far as how all of
these other villains
are coming into the mcu after dying
this plot league does a pretty good job
of explaining and it also does a pretty
good job
at explaining why they still want to
kill peter parker so these are multiple
leaks compiled together by somebody who
the internet seemingly trusts right now
they're coming from reddit user
spideyforever245
so as usual i'll go over all of the
leaks first and then we'll talk about
what it means and i'll give you my
opinion on them after
and reminder i'm still doing my
stormbreaker giveaway all you have to do
is subscribe to me
and cosmicculture link in the
description down below the giveaway ends
at the end of this month
so these leaks are all taken from the
same thread but the person who posted
these leaks kind of did
a q a where people asked him a little
bit about the film and he answered some
questions so we'll just go in order of
how he gave information
the first thing he says is that there is
going to be a rematch between toby
maguire spider-man
and doc ock this is pretty cool because
there have been
a ton of cgi advancements since the sam
raimi spider-man movies
they are retconning doc ock to go insane
again
with the arms but they're also going to
take a sympathetic angle
with him which kind of makes sense
because the last time we left him
if he is from the same reimu universe
which they go on to answer later
he just lost his wife now this leaker
did say that he's not sure exactly
where toby maguire and andrew garfield
spider-man get taken
from their movie like what point in time
but of course they do get taken from
their respective universes and brought
into the main
mcu however it does say that willem
dafoe's green goblin will be in the
movie
from the sam raimi universe and recently
there was another report from daniel rpk
that stated that willem dafoe's green
goblin will be the main
villain of this film and i know a lot of
people are asking
how since he died in the very first sam
raimi spider-man well it seems like
today we
actually kind of have an answer for that
the leak says that the villains are
brought back
from the dead but not really he goes on
to explain
that at the split second between life
and death
the villains were pulled from their home
worlds and into the mcu
so they remember dying and are
essentially dead in a sense so this will
apply to norman osborne the green goblin
dock and electro and alfred molina
already did come out in a very public
interview and stated that john watts
told him that they're going to pick up
with his character where they left off
in that final scene where he's sinking
into the water
and that lines up with this because that
is right before he died
and with electro's so-called death it
kind of looks like he could have
actually
been teleported somewhere else or taken
to another
universe it goes on to say that sandman
was killed
off-screen and remembers his death it's
fair to note that this could be from a
different universe and he said what
happened to sandman
applies to the rhino and the lizard
meaning they could be in the movie
however he doesn't specifically say for
sure that they are in the movie
but with so many villains being in the
movie it definitely doesn't surprise me
at all
now it goes on to say that the reason
that these villains hate spider-man in
this movie and are going to try and kill
him
is because they actually remember
spider-man as the one who tried to kill
them or
actually did kind of kill them so that's
why all of the villains are probably
originally going to be going after tom
holland spider-man and then the other
two
andrew and toby are going to show up and
help because it's kind of their fault
too
and then he goes on to say that he
believes that wanda is the one who
so-called
breaks the multiverse and causes the
multiverse trouble to happen
now we know that one division spider-man
no way home and doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness are
kind of like a three-part movie not
really as far as the actual story of
each individual project is concerned but
simply the effect that they're going to
have on the mcu
and the universe or multiverse now
spoiler alert if you haven't seen the
ending of one division
at the end of one division wanda gets
the darkhold now for those who may not
know what the darkhold is it's an
insanely ancient and
evil book of spells sometimes referred
to as the book of sins
it was actually written by the ancient
elder demon god
c'thun he was banished to another
dimension and it was kind of made for
him to get back into
the earth dimension so we can see how
this book
could cause some serious multiverse
issues after all one of its main
purposes
is to get an elder demon god from one
different reality to
another and not to mention we did have
that nexus commercial in one division
which could be implying that
wanda is a nexus being now a nexus
in the marvel universe act as the
keystones of the multiverse and are
crucial to its ultimate coherence and
stability
in fact typically nexus beans are
watched over by cosmic forces such as
the time variance authority which we are
going to see
in loki nexus beans can affect
probability
and thus the future altering the flow of
the universal time stream
and in one division agatha did mention
that wanda did
a probability hex although wanda didn't
really know what she was talking about
maybe it wasn't a hex but simply the
fact that she was a nexus being
and if she is all of this tampering with
the dark hold that she's doing could
definitely affect the multiverse and
that could cause some pretty big
problems for our friendly neighborhood
spider-man
and this could actually explain why
doctor strange is in spider-man no way
home i mean if we're being honest that
was kind of the first
dead giveaway of the multiverse or
spider-verse in nowhere home when doctor
strange was confirmed to be in the movie
why else would he be there he's not
really the role model father figure type
like tony stark was to peter he's more
of the i have to protect your reality
douchebag type so what this leak
actually does tell us is how some of
these
dead characters can return and it makes
sense they aren't
actually dead they were taken right
before death right before that very
last inch of life was taken from them
because at this time there have been
several reports stating that willem
dafoe's green goblin is indeed going to
be the main villain
and he's going to be from the sam raimi
universe but
how if he died in the very first film
and then alfred molina's doc ock died in
the second sam remy film
and then of course elektro died in the
amazing spider-man 2.
and i also think it's safe to say that
while these villains are being taken
from their respective universes
their spider-man are being taken as well
and that's how they all
end up in rmcu with tom holland and that
explains why these characters would be
attacking
our spider-man tom holland spider-man
they think he killed them because let's
be honest a spider-man suit is
kind of a spider-man suit in the eyes of
the villains they see a spider-man suit
they see spider-man they want to kill
him
but luckily he'll have some help from
some old seasoned veterans
now as far as this leak is concerned i
think it does a pretty good job at
answering some of the questions that we
had about how some of the characters get
to our universe especially after being
dead
as with all leaks you should take them
with a grain of salt but this
is really in line with everything that
we've heard so far the villains seem to
be the same and
obviously line up obviously the
spiderverse multiverse is the same
and how the villains do get into the mcu
does line up with what alfred molina did
say
in his interview how his character was
going to be taken from and pick
up where they left off in that final
moment well how do you pick up from a
final moment right before death
you send them into another universe so
let me know what you think about these
leaks in the comments down below does
this make
sense to you and is this something you
can get on board with
let me know in the comment section down
below don't forget to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu and spidey news don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you